like do the obvious things do the
obvious goddamn things we're all sleep
deprived so sleep more or all heads on
sticks so move often yeah we're all
eating ridiculously fried and processed
foods so eat real food mostly plants not
too much in Michael Pollan 101 you know
we could all we're all neurotic Lee
excessively ruminating in our default
mode Network so practice like strategic
gratitude right
we probably have whacked-out sporadic or
dysfunctional sex lives so circulate
your sexual energy and have good healthy
consensual orgasms right like those
simple things like sunshine get outside
so do those things and if you are
well-rested moving your ass right
hydrated fueled you know and and and and
alive you will have a much higher
incidence I'm getting into some peak
state where everything clicks boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake and we are still
at conscious as hackings awakened future
summit we are now sitting down with
Jamie wheel hello
thanks so much for coming on the show
really appreciate it super excited for
this conversation jamie is the executive
director of flow Genome Project Jamie
you were just giving a talk at the stage
here at awaken future summit what was to
talk about gosh I'm trying to remember
the title it was something along the
lines of the agony or the ecstasy
transformational culture at the
crossroads okay
unpack more for us so you know we're
finding ourselves at this kind of heady
high point of depending on what you want
to call it but like in a placeholder the
psychedelic Renaissance so there's all
of this new information
you know Denver just decriminalized
psilocybin Michael Pollan came out with
his book a little bit earlier we came
out with the book stealing fire and it
sure seems like there was an
unprecedented amount of interest Media
Inc etc and possibility being spilled on
what can happen
we introduce psychedelics into civil
society basically and having been a
student historically of this movement
you know for the last half century just
you know there's nothing new Under the
Sun and there are certain predictable
patterns that show up both in counter
cultural movements in general and
certainly in this one in particular that
are somewhat predictable and so just
kind of laying that laying the some of
those interpreted lenses or frameworks
over the real time heady and exciting
and the world is you know the world is
infinitely possible moment we're having
feels helpful and the things I've been
seeing was just a chance to share it
with other people and be like I don't
know what do you guys think and it for
sure is such but based on the audience
and community response it felt like that
was surprisingly resident you know a
frequent comment was like I've been
thinking things like this all along but
no one's said it like that and so just
the ability that like hopefully say
things in a straightforward way that
other people can pressure test and then
you know they can true it up they can
discard bits they can modify but the
idea like at least bringing you know
instantiating the conversation that is
critical not in a sense of negative
critical but critical in such a serious
and considered and bringing tools to the
analysis hopefully that's that's useful
now we're talking about patterns of
accessibility to psychedelics patterns
of business being involved in
psychedelics patterns of psychedelics
creating more open-mindedness and then
that being a trouble to some of the
economic machinery that is potentially
in place what are we talking about with
these patterns I mean yeah just depends
on yes to all of that so the question is
is you know I keep going back to Tim Wu
who wrote that book the master switch
which is all about information systems
he was also the founder or the coiner of
the term net neutrality he's a media
theorist I think he's at Columbia if not
his NYU but he's a he's out that way and
super smart thoughtful guy and his basic
idea was anytime
revolution and information and he takes
it all the way back to like Telegraph's
and Pony expresses and you know early
radio to TV movies TV and now the
Internet and beyond he's like they
always start out utopian and everybody
thinks this is gonna change everything
and then they always end up hegemonic
Lee centrally controlled and so if you
consider psychedelics and information
technology which is basically providing
people with insights and access to data
they can't normally access and then you
know we should expect it to behave as as
all the prior revolutions have unless er
until proven otherwise and and that kind
of historical perspective on this moment
seems to be potentially lacking and it
would be nice for us to introduce a
little balance like this is never this
you know like there's nothing new Under
the Sun so let's not be surprised to a
bushwhacked when some predictable things
come up maybe one example most recently
that has not fallen under that same
pattern is decentralization technology
blockchain technology yeah although you
know once you get rid of the speculative
bubble or around blockchain and you
actually see where the momentum actually
is it's with Accenture it's really it's
with its with PwC its with large
centralized well capitalized agencies
putting in the backend on distributed
ledger record-keeping and all of the
utopian elements of blockchain at least
you know for now although you know stock
prices up and down everywhere else you
know everywhere yeah you're basically
you know a lot of the frothy utopia and
visionary stuff just kind of went away
when the speculative easy money side
failed and you know for now and and what
we're seeing is again sustainable very
dull but utility level plays made by
tons of established plays in the market
people love to say IBM didn't create the
world's best search engine disruptive
Google did right in that kind of
movement the incumbent never innovates
but there's old that's also a little bit
of exceptions proven the rule that
incumbents often actually continue to
run the table and so it'll sit we'll see
we'll see where the blockchain actually
breaks that pattern because of something
unique and structural about it or
whether it's it comes to that pattern of
capture because of the you know more
persistent trends unfortunate in the
core communities of Bitcoin and etherium
seem to be continuing strong in that in
the good direction yeah now teach us
about what you're thinking around the
wake and future summit could be piecing
it together psychedelics and Technology
and meditation how can we break free
from that pattern I mean I think and
this is 100% congruent with the
decentralized blockchain space I think
that kind of the only chance we have to
avoid you know game theory market
capture 101 just things regress to
someone running the table and locking it
down and then reshaping rules rules and
regs to perpetuate advantage is just a
absolutely unwavering stones to what's
open-source and that's a that's a tricky
thing because we're pouring you know the
sort of psychedelic Renaissance into the
current conditions current cultural
norms and understandings and there has
been a decade plus of kind of
quasi-libertarian very market friendly
do-gooder business ethos which bought
you know the big social stocks the big
tech stocks an awful a lot of runway to
be free and clear of government
constraints be free and clear of civic
up you know oversight or constraint and
that got us to about 2016 right and then
the wheels have come off that might
second the whole make the world a better
place thing they became a absolute
platitude was that legit and arguably
not like all the fluffy pieces on the
sharing economy you know and this and
that around 2010-11 whenever that was
kind of a thing you're like yeah that's
interesting and there's a bunch of
people during generating user-generated
content and all this kind of stuff but
the cap tables are the same so it was
like it was like a new paint job on a
rusty old Chevy and and and you know yes
now that imbalance between the actual
fundamental structures of governance and
capitalization and
value sharing and distribution I've been
kind of exposed and there's a backlash
right now but the possibilities of of
what were what we're up to now it feels
sort of like you have to and this is
true not just with psychedelics this is
true with AI this is true with a host of
emergent volatile fields which is to the
best of our abilities somebody needs to
take a stand for the high ground the
best practice knowing that that is both
essential and inadequate and that there
will always be pirates and subversives
who will work around that but that the
high ground I think there has to be
flags planted as to what we believe is
highest and best and what ought to be
done and what ought never to be tried so
a first principles approach to
psychedelic Renaissance that is open
source yeah okay and then how would this
propagate out into the world as an open
source platform technology yeah we can I
mean you know I mean in some respects it
requires kind of like winding it back a
couple of steps to even be like what the
hell are we talking about because right
now the current narrative has been a
very very procured and very
circumscribed right so we get the
discussion that most of us let's just
assume I'm a mainstream consumer of
media and I haven't heard of this stuff
I haven't been participating in those
is that kind of thing I'm just getting
it because the New York Times write
about it or I'm reading it in Wired or
whatever and that story is medicalised
that story is following a college' sized
okay that story invariably focuses on
PTSD and specifically of highly
sympathetic populations which should be
which is War veterans and childhood
abuse and sexual trauma so you have
basically a a persona or character that
can really not be challenged and
shouldn't be I mean those are people who
have have suffered far more greatly than
any human should expect to be and
deserve the best interventions available
so but that is also that there's a there
is not not a strategy in those being the
faces of the movement it's the same with
Charlotte's Web and Charlotte's law for
CBD all right that was actually
deliberate okay because how can you say
no to a young girl with seizures versus
a STONER in the basement right very very
specific messaging and so that's an
element it's neither good nor bad
choices and and then you end up with the
medical model which is you know all the
clinical trials and everything else are
working within the FDA approval track
and process they're working within
double-blind placebo-controlled they're
working with all the normal stuff
therefore the understanding of how this
works is it works better than Prozac it
works better than talk therapy it has
these benefits in this efficacy and is
cost effective it has better percentage
returns it does whatever it does but
that is just an utterly following mmm
permutation of what psychedelic culture
has been up until that very day time
until this last five years which is both
its success factor how it's getting
through all the gates that have been
shut until now but also not an accurate
reflection in any way of what the last
50 years or psychedelic culture has
actually been and even the thousands of
the most indigenous
use of play medicines as well this just
right like you explained the last five
years I agree that almost certainly it's
been portrayed as assisting psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy is the main
portrayal of this rather than the
awakening properties that have been used
for thousands of years of communion
towards unity all this complex yeah a
very interesting point I'm just however
it ends up unfolding your your bits
about it open sourcing and focusing on
that I would love to unpack that more
with you about how exactly to optimally
roll that out do you have ideas I mean
you know super nascent based on the last
72 hours of conversations with maps and
other places but it's basically my you
know my strong advocacy to Rick and the
team of maps is like take that ground
claim the high ground don't leave it up
to hey we think a benefit court or
nonprofit is probably the best way to go
and we're gonna do it that way but who
are we to say - we are the ones to say
we have taken 30 years of impeccable
high integrity action on behalf of
everybody with no promise of happy
outcome now the happy outcome is here we
are actually going to name the lame for
instance and the simplest thing is there
be court taking responsibility for
sanctioned manufacture and distribution
of clinical and DMA okay great so then
you know they have the power at this
moment to articulate we will only
distribute it to organizations with this
entity structure with this governance
with this charter or building your Bill
of Rights where best practices and we
will modulate that will that stop
pirates and vagabonds not at all but and
we should anticipate and expect that
just like you know ripoff Chinese DVDs
but we should also have you know
have that as clean a signal as possible
to consumers because the consumers of
let's just fast forward 24 months and
you do have expanded access MDMA you
know assisted psychotherapy well whether
or not that's yet plugged into the
health insurance and reinvestment system
whether it's cash up front however its
tax you have people that are in highly
vulnerable states like I have treatment
resistant anxiety depression suicidal
ideation whatever it may be like I am
banged up and hurting and I am desperate
for a solution so to have a clear signal
on the hill this is a safe place
this has reliable quality control this
has solid adherence the best practices
that level you know and this is like my
internal experience healing you know
vulnerability trauma all of it is being
held in in hands that are free from
ethical compromise you know and whether
you know the journalists have ethical
guidelines lawyers and doctors and
therapists have ethical guidelines it
feels like the that the intersection of
this profound of form of therapy with
market forces is a recipe for to put it
absolutely mildly mixed results this is
a good idea is having the ones of the
most robust ethos be the ones that push
the paradigm forward and then also
distribute to others that align with the
ethos and kind of create that as to the
zeitgeist around psychedelics and the
Renaissance and otherwise you can get
this mixed bag of market forces with
psychedelic movement
yeah that's well summarized okay all
right let's move into flow I have to
yeah well let's put it let's to pull to
put it mildly um you know stealing fire
flow Genome Project are just some of the
most important ventures into what is so
unknown about our deepest cognitive
drives and instincts and behaviors to be
able to pursue something with the North
Star and lose sense of time is a feeling
that I think everybody cares about and
and and everybody deserves and so what
has been happening since then at El now
the cutting edge 2019 what are you
learning about flow right now hmm well I
mean even to to walk it back a little to
give us permission to riff which is that
flow is arguably a subset of positive
non-ordinary States right so you can
have positive non-ordinary meditative
experiences transformative technological
experience sexual experience is you know
kinetic experiences dance movement
action sports whatever and and flow is a
specific element of that so if you want
to talk about kind of ecstasy which
would be the bigger you know waist
old-school name that we kind of put on
top of that whole category what is
happening now that wasn't happening at a
couple of years ago I mean I think that
there is a an increasing understanding
of I mean simply five years ago it was
all about alpha and theta waves and
groovy meditation and that was and maybe
a little heart rate variability I
started one so about the mechanisms of
action and now there's a clear rising
tide of interest in gamma waves waking
delta waves
vagal nerve and being on the tone and
the endocannabinoid system which is most
folks don't even know that it's like
nine out of ten American doctors have no
[ __ ] idea what the ECS is all the
researchers Israeli and which is
fascinating because it is such an ass
backwards way it got to be that there
was a u.s. senator who had a son he was
a stoner in college like 20 years ago
was freaked out and called he's like
who's doing any of this research who
knows what the hell's going on
and was my son gonna fry his brain it
was like like like help me like he was
fully indoctrinated like Nancy Reagan
just say no kind of stuff found this out
of the way
completely underfunded Israeli
researcher who'd just been chugging
along on cannabinoid research was like
oh my god
you saved my life you saved my family I
mutated and then it's put like I think
it was State Department funding towards
Israeli research on the endocannabinoid
system so you're like okay fascinating
and they actually discovered that that
the endocannabinoid system basically
functions as a secondary immune system
in our entire system so like our immune
immune system the one everybody thinks
of just chins up white blood cells when
something's wrong it has to go fight it
right the endocannabinoid system
actually responds in real-time
bidirectionally so it actually sends
signals to the brain and back to the
organs so it's this hot 360-degree loop
and it regulates everything from
inflammation to blood pressure to a
gajillion other things you like holy
[ __ ] how is this such a complex system
no one knows about it no one talks about
it and so all the pro cannabis stuff
worth like CBD is good for this and good
for that and it does the other thing you
know and people like really is this just
hype and it's some of it is for sure
commercialized hype but the actual
reason why is because ken but you know
that particular plum accidentally
intersects with our pre-existing and a
cannabinoid system and that is a radical
place of leverage that has not been
medicalised or optimized yet how many
industries is this happening in we're
just in nutrition and in health care
it's just a SPAC words in so many ways
that
the complexity of the body is and all
the biometrics is just where is being
focused on less than the free market
forces driving whatever it's it's it's a
slow down and think from a human centric
perspective is so critical here okay so
yeah so you said vagus nerve a gamma
there's so many there's so much here and
what about activating flow states for
other people around the world that are
watching what would be some of the basic
principle recommendations for people to
have for North Stars and and movement in
that direction losing sense of time yeah
I mean the simple is you know whatever
you can do to get that rusty dial of
your consciousness moving again so the
first thing is just to understand and
this can be tricky like if your life is
locked down and it just feels like
struggle and stress and everything is
hot and you're tired it can be really
hard to have faith that you're actually
wired right for spontaneous joyful
expression like that's it that's one
that kind of comes offline and when
you're not in it it's really hard to
keep the faith that you can get back to
it
but that said one of the first things is
just try and undone your dial and and so
instead of being locked into sort of
21st century normal tired wired stressed
practice you know like do the obvious
things do the obvious goddamn things
we're all sleep-deprived so sleep more
or all heads on sticks so move off in
here we're all eating ridiculously fried
and processed foods so eat real food
mostly plants not too much Michael
Pollan 101 you know we could all we're
all neurotically excessively ruminating
in our default mode network so practice
like strategic gratitude right we
probably have whacked-out sporadic or
dysfunctional sex lives so circulate
your sexual energy and have good healthy
consensual orgasms right like those
simple things like cat sunshine get
outside so do those things and if you
are well rested
moving your ass right hydrated fueled
you know and and and and alive you will
have a much higher incidence I'm getting
into some peak state where everything
clicks as far as specific things if you
really want to get kind of technical
Josh Waitzkin the the chess prodigy who
wrote the art of learning and a bunch of
other books he's a super smart dude and
really good at cracking the code on a
bunch of different disciplines and it's
kind of why I think it's such good
friends with Tim Ferriss and everything
that they are they are gonna like mines
in that way you know he has a four step
process and I think we've modified it at
some points I don't remember which bits
is Josh's cuz we kind of combined it
with some other Red Bull extreme sports
prep that we were inserting and watching
but it's basically you know fuel so
basically have some high quality stable
energy source so you're just glucose to
the brain 101 move like literally engage
in some priming process of and it's
literally like we are monkeys come down
out of trees and look like we're only as
conscious as our movement patterns so if
we're like wobbling around from like
fixed object to fixed object and we're
just heads on sticks and we you know in
our speed are encased in rubber and
leather and we just never are actually
grounded and going through full ranges
of motion alright our consciousness is
constrained as a result so full range of
motion it can be as simple as containing
the stairs instead of the elevator it
can beam all the normal kind of goofy
stuff it's normally about like my belly
is a little fat and how do I burn
calories but like it's actually like
embodied cognition like move because you
will become more awakened alert
breathe changing your respiratory
pattern changes your state of
consciousness you know if you breathe
really slowly you can down regulate your
nervous system if you breathe really
quickly you can up regulate your nervous
system and if you breathe you super fast
deeply for a long time you can
completely transcend your nervous system
and then listen like music is an
amazingly potent so pick your favorite
tunes that amp you up chill you out
whatever combined those and then go and
do the thing the desire challenging and
you want to be at your best or super fun
and you want to be at your best
and then rinse wash repeat there's a lot
of great stuff there Jamie okay so
finding what is you you gave us the the
the fuel with sleep and nutrition and
movement and much more likely to get
ourselves to peak states doing these
things simultaneously we are starving
for meaning in our lives at the same
time so for people that are searching
for that find a North Star what about
that for you hmm
well that for me or the hep for what I'd
like for will you recommend yeah I mean
I don't think we actually have to look
that far like if you just I mean the
starters would be like Hot Tub Time
Machine 2 2007
you know like turn off your social like
dumb down your phone turn off everything
that's not phone text ride-sharing Maps
and music so start like reclaim your
mind share if you're just a condition
dopamine loop [ __ ] monkey you're done
there is no winning that game so reclaim
your time and if anybody whinges or
starts bogging right there that's a sign
of how [ __ ] you already are like I'd
like to mind min by my phone is my clock
you're like oh by a god damn clock like
leave your phone in the kitchen like
laptops like interfering with people's
lives those kind of things so like
festival is just on Jack from the matrix
and it doesn't have to be you know
puritanical you can still make use of
the tools all that kind of stuff but the
endless scrolling the and that stuff
you've done you will not ever have
clarity and awareness to do anything
useful so that would be one amen
the simplest uh you know go and program
those moments that matter most don't let
them be incidental or accidental because
life will always expand and crowd them
out and so the simplest is move
in beautiful nature if you're blessed to
have choice around them and that can be
as simple as sit by the irrigation pond
with some rushes and some ducks for your
lunch instead of again thumbing through
your scroll it can be going to your city
park or your State Park you know if
you're fortunate a natural park or you
know public lands like go go and spend
time there watch the Sun Rise and watch
the sunset
pay attention to what phase the moon is
in your lucky catch a shooting star like
simple simple ass [ __ ] that most zoo
animal humans are just missing at this
point I mean the fact that like kids are
trying to like do chemistry in school
because of Sputnik you know like that's
literally how we ended up with these
ridiculously lopsided science curriculum
you know it was based on the space race
second nineteen fifty three and that
hasn't been upgraded but people can't
identify three living plants outside
their window you know or phases of the
Moon or two constellations in the sky or
right haven't seen a sunrise or sunset
so like do basic human things and your
life will be richer and then ideally if
you can create simple safe appropriate
peak experiences for yourself where you
can't you alluded to the selflessness
and timelessness those kinds of
breakthroughs a simplest respiration we
already talked about it movement and
embodiment and not just like it's not
like jumping jacks or yoga it's like
just literally like just working out the
kinks where we're banged up in balance
etc sexuality is a massively strong
evolutionary driver it has all kinds of
neuro chemical and physiological
imprinting and for the most part it's
tragic sad misguided and unsatisfying
for everybody involved and yet right
there if you're like oh evolution like
absolutely made us be able to do this no
matter what without an instruction
manual that's a pretty strong degree of
encoding can you just jump the tracks
and reroute all of that all of that
narrow chemistry over to the project of
shifting states of consciousness to the
you know spoiler like yes you can you
know and you combine that with breathing
you combine that with movement you then
combine that with movement or or or
music and before you know it you
actually end up with a stackable
practice that is either the kinkiest
biohacking or the nerdiest King you've
ever come across and you're like hey and
if any of that freaks you out just don't
worry about it
back off the stuff that freaks you out
you know respiration will get you there
right movement will get you there music
will get you there every single one of
those can actually get you to the
destination by itself if you want to
stack them in a combinatorial call you
will get further faster and generally
experience more fun if you're me and if
you're really struggling to get to
liftoff of a true selfless experience
just try this is not doctor advice so
don't but if you were gonna sleep
deprivation and fasting right every
traditional indigenous culture that has
not had access to stronger catalysts
basically I mean the loose in Ian's
mysteries you name it all began with
like three days you're asked your
initiate just like fraternity hazing
you're not allowed to sleep and you
don't get anything to eat and that is
gonna bring you much closer to the
liminal zone before anything else you
add on top of that those were so good so
good unplug from the matrix and get one
more thing to add would be I think the
kind of the having a buffet of options
to play with to see where the deepest
meaning comes from playing with those
things and and then creating and
building tinkering making to give
meaning from that process as well those
were those are also good and just the
disconnection in these men massive
metropolis is away from nature sivir
yeah yeah question about what's
happening eight billion humans a hundred
billion come before us build this
incredible world we have but eight
billion now since the Industrial
Revolution
just a derivative and the exponential
technology age AI synthetic biology
neuro technology it's a climate change
there's a lot that's in the hands of
Millennials and Gen Z to try and come up
with solutions to some of the things
that we are most pressing on the on the
planet what are some of your thoughts
around the eras that were approaching
and what are some of the best strategies
that we can have towards tackling this
geopolitically together while continuing
to have some competition but
collaboration mm-hmm well that's massive
they showed you through it like
geopolitical cooperation but then also
some form of seemingly like community
versus Civic kind of kind of Civic
activation I mean I think I mean the
short answer is no idea and I think
about it every day
slightly longer answer it would be you
know the people I've drawn the most
inspiration from lately have been people
in the developing world amazing humans
who are mobilizing needed solutions in
their communities with a fraction of the
resources we have and they they are sort
of acting weather that they're thinking
locally and then acting globally and so
it's the reverse of the bumper sticker
you know they're actually they are
solving for problems that are needed in
their communities and then those
solutions are actually massively
scalable and by design you know or by
default actually by default because
they're coming from places with massive
resource constraints they're ingenious
they're cheap and they're scalable and
they work because if they didn't work we
would never have heard
so this is like that you know our model
you need an NGO you need a big nonprofit
you need an app you need a big exit in
an IP or whatever the hell we think it
through they just like nah man this is
just needed so we started and then it
caught and it grew and we've continued
to try and help it and I feel like
there's an actually there is a role of
you know and I use this to you know
aware of its directional nature but
reverse innovation it actually feels
like I mean what has 50 years of the the
the West and the World Bank and the IMF
holding forth from on high what the
develop you know developing world needs
to do is like nuclear plants well some
of those didn't work hydro oh that
didn't quite work we're not actually
remember we're not actually recommending
anything we still do we're just selling
you our last lap of mistakes you know
with with you know lone shot interest
and what's happening now is the
developing world war for you know for
lack of a better term he's actually
figuring stuff out you said you that
idea of like leapfrog innovation you
know like no one's laying telephone
poles anymore they're going straight to
wireless we're not just getting leapfrog
innovation cascading into the
undeveloped market you're actually
getting a reciprocal or reverse
innovation coming back from those places
and I feel like that's actually weirdly
one of our greatest sources of hope for
ourselves not just for them this is so
interesting looking at developing
countries that have a greater resource
constriction and whereas we have such
abundance that it's the the business
model of a venture capital and in stocks
and and it just and apps and engineers
and versus just something as simple as
having a need in a community filling
that and
that's very interesting that you say
that Jamie it's possible that we could
look to the developing world for a lot
of these leapfrogging technologies it's
very very cool I never would have known
it other than just happened to be
fortunate enough to get to attend a
gathering where some of the major change
agents in the world in Africa India
China Central and South America were
there and they were there because
they've been doing things at scale
touching millions of dispossessed
refugees children etc you're saying and
and one of the one of the leaders of
that community Fred Monica who actually
was Stanford d.school grad and then took
down 100 million bucks to the Gates
Foundation to then create an infinitely
scalable intervention for the arm you
know African leadership over the next
six thousand days he's like in 6,000
days Africa becomes the largest labor
force on the planet and if we haven't
figured out how to do it we're done so
they're they're sort of talent sourcing
was going to townships refugee center
you know refugee camps everywhere else
they were you know and collections of
people that said who are your young
people who have the best chance of
solving for all this and let it
literally be a bubble up crowd source
they went to a SATs they went doing GPAs
and essays they were like come to the
community ask them nominate those kids
bypass undergrad goes straight to
solving basically Africa's unique
version of the STG goals they said
here's the seven don't pick a major pick
a problem start working on it now at a
doctoral level and go solve that [ __ ]
and you're like oh my god and they're
doing it and interestingly their grants
and then when they're graduates
graduates when their grants are done
they do 10% of their income for the next
decade and it's double or nothing it's
like if you're unemployed for ten years
we lost out if you make Bank thank you
and they're basically creating a cost
per child educational curve that drops
off the cliff like it's just diminishing
they've got four campuses and a
returning long-term revenue yield off
their graduates that's growing so
they're indefinitely sustainable you're
like oh my god why is it everybody
we're doing man and we're going to
conversation with like the Finnish
Education Minister that had just boosted
you know was responsible for kind of
seeing Finland to its number-one ranking
all these folks in Western Europe and
North America
and that was what Fred said he's like I
think your guys frog in the hot tub
isn't boiling hot enough we're out of
[ __ ] we're out of time we're bold mean
I'm paraphrasing but a Fred but that's
basically what he said and all you guys
like counting beans and diplomatic
incremental solutions because of the
politics and the entrenched interests of
where you're from is like we're just
doing it because it's what we got and it
needs to be done and I feel like that
kind of you know this but inspiring kick
in the ass is needed all right what a
model that we've also been aiming to
propagate is why not have the education
system have children just tackle the
world's greatest challenges from the
start that this time that they start
school and then that be the focus of the
educational correct project-based
learning around addresses challenges in
the world I mean it seems like that's
what yeah education should be and and
really fun and meaningful for the kids
because the number one complaint about
education knows rise all of us who went
through and is what the [ __ ] does this
have to do with my life and giving kids
empowering an engaged connection to the
world with real-time feedback around
things that matter and not just like
matter on a philosophical level but like
literally cause effect I'm doing stuff I
see the results you know not I'm
balancing an equation and I'm never
going to use this again and so that's
the irony is that we actually create far
more potent and satisfying educational
outcomes when you actually bring the
mandate back to you how do we create
resilient anti fragile communities
forget like how do we groom a knowledge
worker to participate in an exponential
global economy where robots might take
our jobs like [ __ ] that like people
actually need drinking water farmland
right
NATO care literacy you know decent clear
and scalable sustainable housing energy
sources like good old-fashioned it's
like
the that I forget where he's from maybe
it's Kenya but it's the boy who built
windmills is that famous TED talk that
he offered right and the idea of like I
didn't know but I knew my mother was
running out of kerosene and fuel and I
figured out how to make electricity out
of we're most like that kind of
ingenuity you know is what we need good
Jillian's more of and it saves us all
the trouble of being like locked to a
desk learning [ __ ] we know we'll never
need Jaime um more for more for next
time what is going on on playground
earth where do we come from beyond the
3d reality what are your thoughts about
that - well that was a left turn at
Albuquerque all right
wait wait wait a second you have to
restate that in a more language where do
we come from
yeah well I will I will quote philip k
dick here we are pleura forms of god and
voluntarily descended right to reanimate
the yin element which does not know in
doing so we know that we will forget
ourselves in the act of redeeming the
other half which is a terrible irony
because we become what we are attempting
to save and only in remembering
ourselves together is the game won and
we get to return for eternity
so we descend from a source and we need
to remember here that we did that yeah
and that's how to win yeah the infinite
game he calls it an amnesty right the
forgetting of the forgetting but then in
making that commitment if you you know
engage his thought experiment right we
know we're gonna forget and then somehow
I mean this is shiva and shakhty right
is this many ancient stories right if
she if she even shocked you're the one
being the one all the time it's [ __ ]
boring so they split let's play hide and
seek that's a lot more fun
split the play hide-and-seek
to have the game of remembering yeah you
know I mean look it's looks like if it
was just hanging out on the couch all
summer that would be lame but if we turn
out the lights and you go boo let's play
again usually yeah yeah let's play again
yeah we we also do one of the greatest
creations of infinite consciousness is a
place where you experience the illusion
of being separate from it which is earth
yeah
interesting ways to look at the same
thing like that a lot Jamie all right
what's going on with simulation theory I
mean it's a bunch of wanking who the
[ __ ] cares
I mean honestly does it really matter
whether our God is in bits and bytes and
there's an architect or whether he's
wearing bathroom and sandals I mean it
doesn't change the fundamental
existential question it just reskin zit
for the 21st century I mean the laws of
physics are the laws of physics within
the game you can still realize you're in
a game but the rules of physics encoded
into the game still apply unless or
until proven otherwise now if somebody
gets some Easter Egg and figures out how
to unlock the next level did for them
and I'll share that you share the wealth
but really it seems like a remarkably
flimsy rework of good old-fashioned
maker in the sky and whether he's
slinging ones and zeros or the raising
life into clay does it [ __ ] matter to
us I don't think so I'm not aware of
anything that shifts or changes based on
the full commitment to the simulation
hypothesis I mean maybe I'm missing
something but simultaneously it's a if
we want to get behind the qualia of
humans that were there when we invented
language mm-hmm we could run a
simulation with improper resources in a
hundred years potentially yeah and
that's exciting
so there's a lot to analyze with
provided we are still around and have
figured out the lessons we need to learn
right now versus engaging in like
retrospective curiosity but yeah for
sure I mean if we could figure out hey
did we for starters open question did we
ever go up did we ever go wrong do we
have a veer off the DAO or like the
natural unfolding or is everything we're
doing perfect essential that's an
interesting question is this exactly
where it's supposed to be as planet
Earth or have we veered off of the DOE
yeah yeah and you know like back in the
day you had like Ishmael that like book
which was all about the leaders and the
takers which was a gross simplification
of a
bunch of things but very resonant for a
lot of people and then on the other hand
you had folks like like Ken Wilber who
was very much like a directional
progressive Asst saying no it's always
onwards and upwards
and so there's somewhere between those
like the classic fall from grace you
know we need to go some backwards and
find it or ever forwards ever upwards
you know those are just two competing
and conflicting narratives and unless
you get into some interesting
multivariable time-bending
you know I don't know if any if either
those necessarily pencils all the way
through you know so there's like a
fascinating I forget who is it it's the
guy who wrote the I'm not gonna remember
it I'll come back to it it's basically a
ridiculously interesting science fiction
story where time travel is made possible
via basically instead of like June we're
like taking the spice for Hyper stellar
travel travel this one is powered by
orgasm but it's actually a legit Syfy
book it's not and and now I'm mounting
you it's not no it's not it's it's I'll
come back to it and in one of his
stories there's a star that leaves this
is before faster than light travel is
invented and leaves earth puts everybody
in deep hibernation and then gets 100
million years later to the star they set
the plane on but then by that point the
foster in life the two VIII's have
already been there for 99 million years
study of an advanced civilization so
literally the ancestors arrived in time
for their descendants to be like
throwing a party for them and so like
now if we open up that can of worms
there's some potential there's some
possibilities that are nonlinear and not
intuitively obvious mm-hmm perhaps those
are not they're interesting hanko added
to it
okay what about what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
mmm Oh clearly powder skiing in the
backcountry with bottomless like
champagne blower with you know
half-a-dozen dear friends on a bluebird
day I haven't found anything top that
yet just say it in fact in my moments of
despair I do I deal with I'm sure
there's some movies about there's like
lists somebody like what's your happy
place when I get excessively saddened or
despondent about the state of the world
or our response to it I do hold out my
secret exit is the psychedelic pow-pow
Brotherhood we're basically a core bunch
of good friends travel the world chasing
storms both ocean and mountain and we
surf the earth because somebody has got
to feed the holy well it's still around
gee this has been a fascinating
conversation I've had a huge class I
hope you've had a good time yeah huge
thank you they should thank you for
coming on the show and talking to us I
hope that the viewers you guys thank you
so much for tuning in we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking and the the points that Jamie
unleashed on us let's let's get talking
about those with our friends our
families our co-workers online on social
media or maybe disconnect from social
media for long periods of time you know
there's so much nuance there and also
support people like Jamie check out
Jamie's links below also support
consciousness hacking the links to
consciousness hacking or below support
simulation our links are both support
the organization's entrepreneurs and
artists around the world that you
believe in support them help them grow
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much thank you for tuning in
we will see you soon peace